- I bet you've never heard that before.
- No, no one's ever
said that to me before.
Do you like warm hugs?
- I like to be unique, Josh.
- What is that from?
(Kelly laughing)
- Is that the line that
people say the most to you?
- It is.
They say I like warm hugs
or they'll come up to me
and they'll say, do you
want to build a snowman?
- Oh yeah.
- My son just goes summer.
He just comes out saying summer.
He doesn't know the whole
song 'cause he's five.
(Josh laughing)
But he'll just go, summer!,
and it's just he's five and it's awesome.
- Just randomly.
- Just summer.
- Even if its in the dead of winter.
- Yes, yip.
He just loves the song but
he doesn't know the words.
(Kelly and Josh laughing)
Oh, well last time we saw each other,
you surprised me.
And Sean Astin from the Goonies.
- Yes.
So I'm just wondering who
you might've brought today.
Cause I just, did you bring
anyone cool this time?
- Why am I never enough for
you is the real question.
- You are but you really surprise me.
- I know.
- It took me a minute,
I was like is this Sean Astin,
then I was like, oh I freaked out.
I'm in the middle of Montana,
in the middle of nowhere
when I got to meet a Goonie.
- Well, we've talked about this.
So Goonies is like our
mutual favorite movie
of all times.
- Yes, yes.
- And then I did like an actual
table read with those guys
- I know.
- where I played Sloth because right.
- Shut up.
- So it was,
he's amazing and I didn't
bring anyone for you today.
I hope this works for you guys.
- This is enough, you are enough.
You are enough.
Has anyone ever
surprised... 'cause I loved
that I still get,
like still 20 years in this career
Like I still get so excited.
I'm not jaded at all.
I get very excited about meeting people.
Has anybody ever surprised you like that?
- Yes, my.
We're very lucky. I got to
meet like so many cool people
but the one that really won me over
was for my 40th birthday
which I celebrated last year.
I got for my birthday,
a special video from Cameo.
My friends got me a message from Ken Bone.
Ken bone was the guy,
and I became obsessed
with him for some reason,
- Who's Ken Bone?
- I'm going to, well that's
what I'm about to tell you.
(audience laughing)
So Ken Bone was the guy in
like the 2016 election time,
there was a debate
and this one very special
man from the audience
was wearing this tight sweater
you guys remember this?
He had like this sweater and he just was,
he just completely and
boom that's Ken Bone.
Thank you to your crew
for showing you Ken Bone.
- (Kelly laughing)
So I became obsessed,
so that he knew I was obsessed
and they got him to deliver
a message for my birthday.
And it was just, that was so wonderful.
- I love that you have met
so many amazing people.
- Steven Spielberg,
just like every pop star
and I'm like Ken Bone.
- Ken Bone. (laughing)
That's amazing.
- Barbara Streisand?
Yes I've met her.
- Yes, Ken Bone.
- We talk about Ken Bone.
(laughing)
- That's amazing.
- Wait, so how old are your kids now?
- So my kids are...
- One of them is my daughter's age.
- Yes, yes.
- One, one of them is seven, Izzy.
The other one is just turned 11
and Izzy's in a little bit
of a lying phase right now,
which I don't know if
you're going through.
- Does she, does she say,
oh no, I was just faking.
- Yes! I was just faking.
She says, oh just
kidding or just faking it
and I'm like no, you're clinically lying.
- You're a pathological liar.
You're sick. This is a sickness.
(audience laughing)
But it'll be like,
it'll be random stuff.
- Dumb stuff.
- Yep.
Like you just went to the
bathroom and forgot to flush
and she'll be like, no.
And I'll be like,
I haven't done anything
that small since I was four.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So like, I know it's not me.
Your sister's not home.
Like it's not your mom.
So like, it's you.
And she'll be like, I don't
know what you're talking about.
And then I'll like,
I'll find a way to prove it
and she'll go, just kidding.
- I hate that.
I was just faking. I'm
like, no, no, no, no.
It's just called lying
- Yes, exactly.
- It's just hard sometimes,
like how do you get them to stop?
I don't know if you find
out the phone a friend,
but you shared an awesome moment
with your family recently.
I love this moment as well, let's see it.
- [Josh] Come on girls.
I got a surprise for you guys.
- Right there.
- Grandma!
(laughing)
(kids shouting)
(audience clapping)
- I mean, that's how long two years?
- Two years.
- That's so sad, that's
like so many families though
because of COVID.
- Because of COVID,
they hadn't seen their
grandparents in two years
and I wanted to surprise them.
And I was away shooting in London
a project up until last week.
And so I surprised them as well.
So it was like just surprise overload.
And there you didn't see it on the video,
but the tears in their eyes,
just the pure joy in
their eyes was so amazing
and so incredible
and I know everybody here and elsewhere
has had this experience,
but it's just like losing that contact,
losing that proximity was so tough.
- Not only for your kids,
especially the grandparents.
I know my mom was like,
I feel like they grow
so fast at these ages.
- A hundred percent.
- So it's like,
I feel like I missed out that's you know,
my mom had said that.
- It was, it was incredible.
- Well, I could talk about
your family the whole show,
'cause I love your
family and so do my kids.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So what is Wolf Like Me about?
- Wolf Like Me is about a
character named Boba Fett
who is just kidding.
- I was like what. (laughing)
- Just wanted to make
sure paying attention,
Woo woo!
Just wanted to make sure
everybody was paying attention.
- I'm on.
- So Wolf Like Me,
it's an amazing story
between these two characters
named Mary and Gary,
both going through very
difficult periods of their lives.
My character Gary is a single father
and he just,
things have happened in his
life that have been tough
and his daughter who's 12 years
old is going through a rough
patch and he's closed off
and then he has this sudden encounter
with this woman named Mary
and the two quite literally
and metaphorically
crash into each other's lives.
And this is a story about
how difficult love can be
and also how much baggage
we bring into relationships.
- Hmm.
- But it's done through the prism
of some really exciting
and cool genre stuff
that I can't talk about
- Because then you'll ruin it.
- because then I'll ruin it.
But it is one of the
most incredible things
I've ever been a part of.
It is just so wonderful.
Abe Forsyth who directed me
in a movie called Little
Monsters that I did
with Lupita Nyong'o directed this as well.
And he calls me up and he goes,
Josh, I've got the script.
This is an Australian accent right now,
(laughing)
in case you were like,
what's happening now.
- Well you have to point it out
I don't know if you're nailing it.
- No, they know, they know, anyways
he says, yeah, yeah, Dingo.
(Kelly laughing)
He calls me up and he said Josh,
I've got this project.
It's going to go next month in Australia.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- You and Esla Fisher,
who I love,
- Love.
- obsessed.
And you would have to fly
here quarantine for two weeks
and then we shoot for
three and a half months.
- Sounds like a party.
- And I was like,
I don't know I'm sort of like a father.
So like that's not a good idea right now.
And he's like,
just read the script and I read the script
and I am telling you,
I got to the end of the first episode
and then I immediately
tore through the next five
and was like, I'm in.
I have to do it.
- I love it, it's that
powerful that's cool.
- It's incredible.
But it was great.
I think everyone will
find that it was worth it
to abandon my family.
(laughing)
- Be a dead beat father
so that you could all be entertained.
- Oh my god I love you so much.
So you did it in Australia.
I love Australia. Did
you see any wildlife?
Like, cause y'all shot in
like the Outback, right.
- So when you go to the Outback,
what do you expect to see?
- Well kangaroo's?
- Kangaroo.
Not a damn kangaroo.
(audience laughing)
- Not one?
- Not one.
Not only that I would get
to set at like 5:00 AM,
5:00 AM or 4:30 in the morning.
And I get there and my
makeup artists would be like,
did you see the kangaroos?
- I knew that was going to happen.
- And it was like, no.
She goes, oh you must come in too late.
I'm like, it's 4:30 in the morning.
(laughing)
What kind of (beep) do the
kangaroo's have to get to
that they're like sorry, I'm running late.
4:30 AM you got into late.
So it was always like,
I feel like it's a conspiracy.
- Like, so everyone else.
- Everyone saw kangaroo's
and then Esla pointed one out
and it was like 30 miles away.
(laughing)
It could have just as easily
been a man in a kangaroo outfit.
- Like a bunny.
- Like just a large bunny,
a very unhealthy bunny
jumping in the distance.
- I want to ask you this cause
you've done so much Broadway
that you've forgotten your lyrics, right.
I've heard that you kind of did on stage
and people think it's kind
of a fun thing with you.
- Yeah, though it's not.
(laughing)
It's not a fun thing. That's a nightmare.
- I know I'm bad at it too. Are you?
How are you at it though?
Cause here's my thing.
Somehow I will say something
it will somehow rhyme,
it won't make sense, but
it will somehow rhyme.
- So that's what you're taught to do.
What's interesting is I did not do that.
(laughing)
I took the opposite approach
and forgot the human language,
forgot the entirety of
our experience vocally
as a collective species
and just stopped talking
as the music was playing very loudly.
It gets worse.
The stage manager was
screaming the line at me
going you're making things up again.
And all I heard was eeeeee.
- What.
I had like tinnitus or I
was a living nightmare.
- Oh you had like a ringing?
- I had like a ringing sensation.
- I've had that happen once to me.
- It was like,
it was like energy up above got
bored that day and was like,
let's play with Josh's life.
And it was like, this is insane.
And then my co-star was
screaming the line at me
and I still couldn't say the line.
I couldn't hear anything.
And then can I curse on your show?
- We'll bleep it.
You'll bleep it out, good.
This is how I got out of it, okay.
Live theater,
people paying $500 a ticket
to see Book of Mormon.
I looked out at my cast and said,
What the (beep) is my next line.
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
I am a trained professional.
Don't try that at home.
- But you know what if I'm at that show,
best experience ever.
- But here's, here's the worst part.
They were so confused.
They weren't even enjoying it.
They were just like,
this is a very weird part
of this show right now
does this happen every night?
This script feels like it needs work.
And from that point on, in Book of Mormon,
I actually in the song,
I had an actual book of Mormon
where I pasted the lines so
that when I opened it up,
I don't care now
- That's clever.
- I did it 10 years ago, whatever
whatever audience, you
saw it after the fact.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Spoiler alert.
- That's clever.
- I know and then from then,
because then you get in your
head and you're like oh,
it's going to happen again.
Always when I watch the voice,
I'm always like so nervous,
'cause the kids are learning
it like every week, new songs.
- Dude, they just, they learn
it like quickly like that.
That's why it's hard to do but anyway,
I struggle a lot with lyrics.
I have, since I was a kid,
like I don't have a really
great memory in general
when it comes to stuff like that.
So I figured since you
suck and I suck at this,
we should play a game and who's the worst.
(laughing)
- Great, yes.
(audience cheering)
Yes.
- Does that sound like fun?
- Yes please.